9 11 attacks led to a 20-year war in
afghanistan as u.s forces and their
allies sought to target al-qaeda
fighters and the taliban which was
accused of harboring them tens of
thousands of afghans were killed and
many lives turned upside down let's
bring in charles stratford now who is
live from afghanistan's capital kabul
charlie 911 led directly to the collapse
of the taliban regime which had ruled
afghanistan before the attacks today the
taliban are back in power in afghanistan
how are people
in afghanistan reflecting on this
anniversary
i think everybody certainly that we've
spoken to is is reflecting with a sense
of relief that this 20-year-old war is
now over
but there's great trepidation and
anxiety about the future with this new
taliban interim government in power
despite the promises
that that government has made not only
to afghans but to the international
community about protecting human rights
giving women a role in society for
example allowing them to work promising
not to allow afghanistan to be used as a
base for groups to launch attacks uh on
foreign countries i mean the the impact
of the last 20 years on this country has
been immense as you say tens of
thousands of civilians have been killed
in the fighting thousands of both afghan
soldiers
government forces and
obviously allied u.s allies troops
but there have been also some very
positive things that have happened as
well and that's important to recognize
we have seen
relative steady economic growth over the
last 20 years
there have been
for example
far better figures when it comes to
education far more girls attending
school
there have been the beginnings of if you
like private private investment
um
so there have been
important gains made um
and and and that must not be forgotten
we've been speaking to a number of
people today in kabul
about their experiences over the last 20
years let's have a look
in zalgul's home was destroyed during
fighting between u.s led forces and the
taliban 14 years ago
his brother and one of his sons was
killed
he and his family have lived in this
camp for internally displaced people in
kabul ever since
he blames the united states and its
allies for the pain they've endured
in the past 20 years we've suffered so
much that at times we've hardly been
able to eat for days all afghans have
been through terrible hardships
bombardments fighting our houses
destroyed the war lasted so long because
we are afghans and we will fight for our
country
in central kabul today taliban fighters
guard former government buildings and
abandoned foreign embassies
the challenges the movement faces after
what it describes as victory in a fight
for national sovereignty are immense
it's been 20 years since the 9 11
attacks and the soon after u.s lead
invasion to hunt down osama bin laden
and remove the taliban from power
then followed what the taliban described
as two decades
of foreign occupation
the foreign forces have gone the taliban
are back in power
and the un says that afghanistan is
facing a humanitarian and economic
catastrophe
this is the old american embassy
once a hub of cia and military planning
and one of the most important centres of
u.s foreign policy in the world
now it's just an empty shell
hamid ghoul was 24 when u.s led
coalition forces invaded he is scared
about what the future holds
in the last 20 years my hopes changed
but now they've been left behind all
afghans thought we would get close to
the rest of the world when the americans
were here but now we have to wait and
see again what the future will bring
despite his doubts hamid says he wants
the world to give the taliban a chance
all my life i've experienced only war i
just want to sleep with ease i just want
to wake up with no fear i'm tired of
saying goodbye to my family as i leave
for work afraid i'll never see them
again
this is one of many graveyards on
hillsides surrounding kabul
here are buried some of the estimated 50
000 afghan civilians killed in the last
20 years
inzaghul says he also wants the
international community to accept the
taliban he wants education for his
children who are born into war
he wants to chance for them all to start
their lives again
and so so much is dependent on the
international community um accepting the
taliban and the taliban sticking to
their commitments the promises that
they've made as they say on human rights
uh protecting women um and on as i say
not
letting this country for example be used
as a as a base for terror attacks to be
um launched against other countries the
un is warning that if aid is not
released that aid currently being frozen
because the taliban because of the
taliban have retaken power the u.n
saying that if that aid is not unfrozen
potentially almost 100 percent of the
population of afghanistan could be in
poverty by around about this time next
year
so in terms of what everyday afghans are
thinking they're thinking well we're
very relieved thank god the war is over
but there are huge anxieties and
challenges ahead